hello there now sometimes when we're
recording the slammer days we perform
the experiment what before we want the
intro you guessed it this is one of
those times
ya can't really hide the fact of damage
or yourself covered in cornstarch down
what we doing with this little torch so
basically I'm going to try fire
breathing today and still that looks
like in slow-mo be pretty badass I think
and yes I'm gonna cut the heat on that
that's good alright that looks like in
slow-mo
but war before yeah all right so what is
that fuel of choice okay today we've got
some cornstarch that's what I go for
because a sort of safer than using
kerosene because it's not like
inherently flammable then it's not a
professional so I put flammable liquid
in this glob
yeah I never done it before so basically
I'm going to do is Jam as much
cornstarch into my mouth as I possibly
can
yeah and then sort of blow out a fine
powder and then it will be flag rate by
burning the next layer of material and
just sort of create a big fireball
quickly let me notice that pretty much
anything in powder form is vulnerable
yeah weirdness yeah just cuz even flour
it's easily burnable so that's what does
it just heats up the next layer of
materials burns it's so fine
alright let's punch them in
how's it taste mmm
cool
it look like a bloody explosion space
stuff fly out there's a face shot
Oh a nice you do the fight
let's start at school
what's it taste like like
for tacos or burritos like a tortilla
yeah but that goes here so this is
all-seer all right
solid video flames look good then you'd
only good your absolute state record
such I think it's a good look for me
yeah pull off some Twitter if you want
buy the shirts if you want maybe just
sit there you want them to just watch
the videos man whatever you want
whatever feels right
do the next one
that didn't look as good did it look as
impress no no okay
this video was sponsored by audible.com
and if you would like a free audiobook
when you sign up you can use this link
there's over 150,000 books to choose
from and I haven't listened to the more
yet it's going to take some time this
week I recommend The Hobbit
because the last movie just came out and
it's the perfect time to listen to The
Hobbit in my opinion and you can speed
it up or slow it down as well depending
on how fast you listen it's pretty neat
alright that's it thanks for watching
bye